[Music]
so what happens is when a man simps for
a woman right it puts him in the
feminine and it puts a woman in her
masculine yeah and so what what happens
is is that the man starts to be a woman
and a woman starts to be a man and so
what happened and and so I'm just saying
and so what happens is is that the
Dynamics of the relationship get skewed
and so women while they may like because
women generally lack attention you're
women you lack attention right however
too much attention from a simp you ain't
gonna respect
himself just think of the guys that you
guys have liked the most I mean are they
really simping for you
and you want it do you know a man only
you can only you only feel like the
woman is taken to man's role if the man
is not providing and doing the
because a woman will automatically go
into a feminine energy as soon as she
finds that alpha male whatever you want
to call it
why would why would men provide
traditionally when they don't get
traditional women exactly but like like
how many how many of us are 22 year old
virgins on here
right me but it's also a party
there's a lot of influences
you see what you were saying about women
like back from his country want meant to
sit for them I think the difference is
because of the cultural difference
there's no question
woman's morals
let me land right you see in this
country because of the culture and the
way women will get showered on women
like I can go to a club and just get
into a club and be on a man's table like
that yeah
that's not but let me learn no but it is
but I tell you why it is
if I don't know you yeah I owe you
absolutely let me speak I owe you
absolutely nothing as a man who doesn't
know you of course so what happens is
the simp culture within the Western
world has become a norm so men will say
okay cool and this is why I speak to men
men I'm going to speak to you right
because if you are out here with a lot
of money you may have a lot of money
stop giving pretty women yeah stop
giving pretty women attention because
what happens is you will lose your
resources you will lose your money you
will lose your time and what will happen
is they will take your time effort
resources all the things that you built
up and they'll be on to the next yeah
the difference is now when you go out
and you can spend a bag and buy a bottle
you're that guy now no but do you know
what it is
guys guys
okay this is this is a warning stop you
can't be over talking the host it's
ruining the show the chat is picking up
on it you cannot be over talking I could
be a multi-millionaire right
but if I don't know you I have no
obligation to be spending hundreds
thousands on you right the problem is in
this generation when we're talking about
simping there are guys that are
multi-millionaires or maybe not even
more they just got a little bit of money
and what they feel like doing and it's
for me is like this shows men do not
know how to get women without resources
right they feel like their resources can
get exactly women right and a lot of the
time it can because women love money
women like shiny that's all right but if
men understand if you learn to focus on
yourself and understand how to get women
without resources when you have the
resources you understand that those
resources regardless of whether you have
them or not don't it doesn't matter you
can still get women but what's happened
in this Society a man will have a watch
on his hand right we'll have a chain on
his neck yeah right he'll be at the club
yeah we'll buy multiple bottles and he
thinks okay cool I'm gonna get some
women true I'm gonna tell you bro stop
doing that because the bottom line is
those women that you're trying to
attract do not give a damn about you
yeah but then maybe you don't give a job
that's what I'm trying to say if I've
got a fortune I'll say like say I've got
50 right now say I blew one rack on
goals in the club that doesn't make a
dent in what I have but you look like
that you look like the guy that's
spending money so just because you
because you've just spent enough to make
you look like the guy but not enough to
Dent like your value your financial but
that's what I'm saying that's the
culture today that you it has to be a
cup to it there has to be a cup to how
much you spend on the this random girl
in the club to make you look like the
man but not the simp but the thing is I
have a question for the girls if you
really like a guy do you does it matter
how much he spends on you like you if
you really if you if you really really
like a guy
not at all no I believe that um when I
like a guy I just I care about his
presence
um how he treats me how he talks to me
these things obviously as a girl you do
like the final things in life or whatnot
but it's not what matters the most for
me personally anyways money is easy if
you have if I have a million pound in
the bank and I give you a thousand pound
that's easy if I have 50 pound in my
account and I give you 20 that means
more but this is the problem though
people think because you have money or
that guy you're not that guy because you
have money anyone can make money the
thing is you're not making that the way
you carry yourself
it's got nothing to do with money
because you can go and spend a thousand
pound on a female but the way you carry
yourself makes you that guide you
because then she can respect you even
more by how you present yourself and
that is because you can go to a chicken
shop date whatever chicken shop get her
chicken and mention a word they're
called respect and the thing is is that
if a woman respects you doesn't matter
how much money you have in fact it
doesn't matter how much money you don't
have we've all been with broke guys if
she respects you as a man because you
show that you are a man you don't have
to simp your money don't mean anything
okay so can I just say something please
yeah go on bro uh like like for for some
guys eh simple to them is not simply
it's fishing right so uh let's say I see
this girl I want to get her right but I
know she's into money she's into going
you know buying her flashy things and
spending money on her that's that's
what's gonna get me to be with her or to
sleep with her right so for me I
wouldn't worry about
all the money that I'm spending or
everything that I'm doing for her in the
long run I just see the bigger picture
can I say something yeah get get her
into bed right oh so uh so so for men
some for some men same thing is not
simple
so wait a minute
so what you're saying is that she's a
prostitute no no yeah
I don't know what I'm saying that's not
what I'm saying what I see is to get her
into bed right that's the money yeah
hang on wait so what you're saying is
you spend money on a woman yeah to get
her into bed but you know is that not
prostitution
[Music]
because you want something from him no
no let me get you no you know the
difference one at a time let him speak
let me get to a point if I know I if I
know you are you are more likely to be
impressed if I pull up on your on your
driveway with a bench right right I'll
go and rent that bench to pull out
to come together yeah but the thing is
no no but let me get to the point Sorry
women like flashy things right if I know
if I go if I go out yeah if I pop two
barrels three barrels or if I go up if I
go out with a bench I'm definitely going
home with a go then then I'm [ __ ] I'm
doing it yeah but let me tell you
something but that's an investment I
just feel like as a if you if you really
like the guy it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what I'm saying that's
true in my 20s I'm 41. yeah but in my
20s when I was going out I could go out
without a pins true and come back with
true times you know what but you know
why why because I knew how to talk to
women because
and the thing is the problem now is the
problem now is guys don't understand how
to interact with wimp sorry no I think
I've got a cold guys don't know interact
with women oh hang on
so their money
someone knows me I think today can I say
something about you I think today of
women expect more I don't think it's the
fact that guys don't know how to speak
to women expect more wait like I know I
know certain goals that if a guy is nice
they come up to them they've got a nice
approach they've got a good energy and
they're not taking them Shard they're
not going personally I don't understand
that question I agree with you women
expect more and they offer less we offer
lessons
that's how women are though yeah do you
know what I don't know I mean like
you've got to be like that you gotta
expect more because you got you know you
know what you want from a guy and you
have to as a guy and the guy comes into
your life and he's trying to get to know
you and you have a certain expectation
of that guy actually doesn't reach that
expectation I didn't mean like offer
less in in terms of like compared to him
I'm saying like as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible